[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the test
website comm and today we're gonna be
looking at a different trap and it's the
siberian trap and it derives from the
smith more gambit in the Sicilian
defense and we'll go ahead and take a
look at that it starts out with pawn to
e4 and black responds with the Sicilian
defense with pawn to c5 and white is
going to move pawn to d4 and after black
captures then White's going to go into
the Smith more gambit offering up an
extra pawn here and Black's going to
take and why it's going to recapture the
pawn with Knight to c3 Black's going to
develop his Knight to c6 why it's going
to develop his Knight to f3 Black's
going to continue with pawn to e6
White's going to develop his Bishop to
c4 getting into an active square aiming
down on the f7 square and allowing him
to castle and Black's going to bring his
Queen to c7 it's actually a pretty
active square in the Sicilian offense
for the Queen as it can come down on the
King side so from here why it's going to
castle
Black's gonna bring his knight to f6 and
the trap is almost in place from here
White's going to move his Queen to e2
which we will see is going to
be a mistake once we set the trap and
the trap is laid with Knight to g4 and
from here you know you'll see a lot of
questionable moves and one of the most
common question moves you'll see is
light knows that Black has this threat
of queen - H - checkmate but he knows
that he has a night here on f3 so what
wife's gonna try to do a lot of times he
knows he has an extra defender here so
he knows black can't come in right away
so he's gonna go ahead and try to take
away this threat and move pawn to h3 and
this is actually a huge mistake because
black can actually move his knight to d4
and capture this queen now if for some
reason white decides to not have his
queen captured he's going to get
checkmated meant for instance he moves
his queen let's say he moves his queen
away - let's say d1 then black can
simply come in and capture on f3
checking the white king and blacks next
move he can come to h2 and checkmate
same thing if we try to take this night
which is attacking the Queen let's say
with Knight to d4 then black can simply
come to h2 for checkmate so white has
the option he can either lose his queen
which obviously is going to be
a clear win for black or if he tries to
save his queen then he's going to get
checkmated so very brilliant brilliant
trap and you'll see this one more often
than some of the others so hope you guys
enjoy this one and look out for another
video in the future thanks guys